à minsk
la colère ne retombe pas ils étaient
plusieurs centaines ce mardi à s'être
rassemblés pour protester contre
l'arrestation de maria kolesnikova cette
militante de l'opposition aurait été
interpellé par les autorités biélorusses
à la frontière avec l'ukraine
dimanche dernier plus de 600 personnes
ont été arrêtées lors d'un rassemblement
massif contre le pouvoir des
arrestations dénoncée notamment par la
france
la france condamne avec la plus grande
fermeté les arrestations arbitraires et
les pratiques d'exil forcé de plusieurs
membres du conseil de coordination ainsi
que de nombreux manifestants ces
derniers jours de son côté le président
biélorusse alexandre loukachenko s'est
entretenu avec des journalistes russes
selon lui le sort de la biélorussie est
étroitement lié à celui de son voisin
russe
ce n'est pas le moment de vous relâcher
vous allez également avoir bientôt
certains événements politiques et
probablement sans aucune raison vous
savez où nous en sommes arrivés avec
l'establishment et les dirigeants russes
si aujourd'hui la biélorussie s'effondre
la russie sera la prochaine en attendant
alexandre loukachenko n'entend pas céder
à la pression il exclut de démissionner
son départ pourrait dit il être
considéré comme un abandon lui qui est
au pouvoir depuis un quart de siècle